[Musique]
à 120 me vidéo venait acquérir un film
pour un jour ou même 2 et profiter d'un
panel de films incroyables des films
mais aussi des séries ne possédons pas
la dernière saison de game of thrones
mais si vous êtes amateurs d'heroic
fantasy
je vous conseille la série xena la
guerrière une soudaine envie d'avoir
accès à des dizaines de films de films a
pas du tout de l'extérieur j'écoute
c'était un micromania n'est pas non
profiter d'un service personnalisé à la
personne oui monsieur bianchi vos dvd
viennent d'arriver
ils vous attendent ok très bien d'accord
[Musique]
saint-rémy vidéo c'est l'axé le plus
rapide à des dizaines de vidéos
après internet connaissez-vous l'acteur
jean reno
[Musique]
micromania ouais non cliquer sur le
macaron pour ta bonne et à la première
chaîne qui a eu l'idée de faire des
vidéos humoristiques sur internet
après studio beagle et lacazette
moustache aussi après golden moustache
et linéaire net après une rnet astrid
après astrid due forme
après hugh venant échouer c'est vrai que
tu allais m intrigue de mer